una sucesión está definida recursiva
mente como sigue nos dice que el término
n es igual al término n menos uno por el
término en m2 y nos dicen que a 0 es 2 y
aún no es 3 así que hay que calcular a 4
eso es lo que vamos a hacer entonces
como condiciones iniciales nos dicen que
a 0 es 2 y que a 1 a 1 vamos a ponerlo
con este color a uno es 3 cómo calcular
y amos a 2 bueno pues a 2 simplemente
será nos dice que a 2 lo podemos
calcular como a 2 menos uno que sería
uno por a
2 - 2 que sería a 0 entonces simplemente
sería multiplicar a 1
por 0 a 0
entonces esto cuánto vale a 1 vale 3 y a
0 a 0 vale 2 así que el producto
completo sería 3 por 2 que son 6 muy
bien ahora vamos a calcular a 3
no vamos a ponerlo con otro color a 3 a
3 sería sería a 3 sería a 3 menos uno
que es a 2 a 2
por a 3 - 2 que es a 1
a dos por uno ahora cuánto vale a 2 a 26
y será x a 1 que es 3 así que el
resultado simplemente es 6 por 3 que son
18 y finalmente llegamos a donde
nosotros queremos que es calcular a 4 a
4 simplemente nos damos cuenta que es el
producto de los dos anteriores verdad
entonces el anterior sería a 3 por 2 por
a 2 ahora bien a 3 era 18 mientras que a
dos es 6 así que hay que multiplicar 18
por 6 y cuánto es 18 por 6 bueno 6 por 8
son 48 y llevamos 4 6 por 1 son 6 y 4
son 10 así que son 108 la respuesta a
ver quién es a 4 es 108